Losing something we love, or someone who is
dear to us, can cause us a lot of pain.
To accept the loss and overcome the pain,
we often go through five stages of grief.
Denial, anger, bargaining, depression, and
finally acceptance.
First comes Denial.
When we experience a loss, we feel shocked
and numb, and then simply deny what happened.
The refusal to accept the truth temporarily
protects us from all the negative thoughts
and consequences of the tragedy.
Denial gives us a bit of room to breathe.
Then comes Anger.
We feel furious and resentful, often blaming
ourselves or others for the catastrophe.
Anger shields us from pain.
We feel less vulnerable and more in control
of the situation.
Then there is Bargaining.
It is an attempt to regain control and negotiate
the reality of the loss.
We try to make promises or seek outside solutions
to somehow reverse the irreversible.
When the loss sinks in, Depression follows.
We go through feelings of sadness and despair.
We withdraw from others.
As we face reality, depression can help us
process our grief.
Healing can begin.
Lastly, there is acceptance.
We come to terms with what has happened.
This does not mean we forget, but we find
a way to integrate the loss into our life.
We may now honor the memories of those who
have departed and look ahead, knowing that
after all, life goes on.
Getting to acceptance, however, does not mean
it is over.
Grief is a complex emotional response to loss,
particularly the loss of someone we love or
something deeply meaningful — like a job.
This process is unique to each of us and is
not always linear.
Often we cycle back, revisit stages or experience
some entirely new emotions.
Sometimes it can feel like we are regressing,
but with the support of others and each new
day, time will help heal our wounds.
Elisabeth Kübler-Ross, a psychiatrist who
supported those facing their own death, observed
the five stages in the 1960es.
She later wrote:
"The most beautiful people we have known are
those who have known defeat, known suffering,
known struggle, known loss, and have found
their way out of the depths.”
What do you think? Have you ever experienced a significant loss
in life?
And if so, did you go through these 5 stages
or did you take another path to deal with
it?
Please share your thoughts and
insights in the comments below.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com